مشهد مالوف فهذه اوكرانيا حيث الحرب تختبر
طول النفس كل يدعي الصمود ومراكبه المكاسب
في الميدان او هو اذا تعذر ذلك حديث عن
افشال خطه الطرف الاخر من ذلك مثلا قول
الروس انهم اسقط طائرات مسيره الاوكرانيه
كانت تهم بمهاجمه موسكو ومسيرات غيرها
كانت تحلق في اجواء شبه جزيره القرم
هناك جنوبا كثف الجيش الروسي هجماته
الجويه لكن الاوكرانيين يؤكدون احراز
قواتهم تقدما باتجاه ميليتوبول بوابه
القرن اخترقت تلك القوات اخيرا كما قالت
خط الدفاع الروسي الاول على جبهه
زابولوجيا ويبدو انها تستفيد الان في
تقدمها بما تراه ضعفا في تحصينات خط
الدفاع الثاني
هنا تقدم وهناك في ضخموت اخر بحسب هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه في طريق استعاده
المدينه المنشود اما في دانيسك حيث عززت
القوات الروسيه مواقعها فتشير سلطاتها
الماليه لموسكو الى مقتل مدنيين في قصف
اوكراني على مدينتين في المقاطعه قد تشهد
تطورات الساعات الاخيره باستعاده كييف
زمام المبادره على الارض ربما كسب هجومها
المضاد فاعليه الاكبر مع وصول صواريخ
بريطانيه وفرنسيه بعيده المدى لكن الجدل
ما يزال محتدما بشان جديه الحلفاء
الغربيين في تزويد اوكرانيا باسلحه قادره
على قلب معطيات الميدان لماذا يتاخر تعزيز
قدراتك الدفاعيه السؤال مطروح في المانيا
التي توجه رئيسه لجنه شؤون الدفاع في
برلمانها اللومه الى المستشار الاف شولز
لا تفهم ماريا غناس
دواعي احجام شولت تسليم صواريخ كروز
الالمانيه من طراز تاوروس الى اوكرانيا
لعلها الخشيه من امكانيه اطلاق الصواريخ
الحديثه من اوكرانيا لاصابه اهداف في
الاراضي الروسيه فهل هي ذاتها الدواعي
التي تؤخر قرار واشنطن بخصوص تزويد كييف
بصواريخ ارض ارض من نوع التعكمز الامريكيه
هذه الصواريخ التكتيكيه التي قد يصل مداها
الى 300 كيلومتر تعمل بالوقود الصلب
وبالامكان اطلاقها من انواع مختلفه من
المنصات والقاذفات الصاروخيه
يقول هؤلاء الاوكرانيون ان ذاك الصنف من
الصواريخ بامكانه انقاذ ارواح وانه هو ما
تحتاجه بلادهم لكسب الحرب وزاره دفاعهم
تطمئنهم بانها مساله وقت فالامريكيون كما
تؤكد كييف طلب تحليل بعض النقاط المتعلقه
بالطلب وباعداده